et on revient sur ses négociations avec
nos deux invités douglas y est
professeur de droit et spécialiste de
sciences politiques américaines et
karine déchets golovkov professeur
invité à l'université d'état de moscou
c'est le débat de ce soir
bonsoir à tous les deux et merci d'être
avec nous ce soir sur rtl france sur la
table des discussions américaines russes
deux propositions de traiter soumise à
washington par moscou interdire tout
nouvel élargissement de l'otan à
l'ukraine ainsi qu'à tout autre pays et
empêcher les activités militaires
proches de la frontière russe dans les
pays de l'ancien espace soviétique la
russie demande des garanties sur sa
sécurité est ce qu elle a raison de se
sentir menacé par l'otan karine d'échec
le fco
nom sera la question n'est pas tant pour
l'instant en tout cas celle d'une menace
directe mais plutôt on va dire d'une
évolution du certaines tendances qui
fait que
l'otan se rapproche de plus en plus des
frontières de la russie que les bases de
l'otan se développe depuis non plus près
des frontières de la russie sans parler
des programmes acquis sont développées
notamment en ukraine de formation des
militaires et donc du soutien très
concret de ce pays qui connaît quand
même un conflit ouvert sans oublier par
ailleurs que l'otan les états unis ont
de leur côté certains intérêts qui leur
sont propres et qui sont absolument
incompatibles avec les intérêts la
russie la question de savoir si les
intérêts des uns sont légitimes pourquoi
ce désir ne serait pas alors sur le fond
washington s'est dit prêt à discuter des
propositions russes c'est l'objet des
échanges de cette semaine mais sur la
forme à les états unis et multiplie
depuis des semaines les discours de
fermeté s'il ya une agression de plus en
ukraine cela aura des conséquences
massive et cela coûtera très cher c'est
ce qu'a encore déclaré récemment à la
presse un haut responsable américain
c'est un jeu d'équilibriste pour joe
biden douglas y est oui la ville
diplomatie publique qui fait sur les
ondes des télévisions en une seule après
pardew est là les deux côtés fonte des
neiges de l'idiot dans les négociations
mais la réalité s'ils se rencontrent et
en plus il est d'accord pour faire vrai
négociateur
en europe on pense que poutine et marc
gêné les marginaliser les européennes et
et c'est vrai ça c'est bien sûr comme un
affaiblissement de l'alliance
transtlantique mais en fait les deux
partis qu'ils ont la capacité militaire
les deux parties si ce qu'ils peuvent
faire une négociation qui peuvent offrir
quelque chose sont seulement la russie
les états unis donc je fonce les
porteurs privés en team contre eux
blinken entre brydon entre poutine
contre le la après des politiques
étrangères russe se soit plus décisive
pour forcer une décision offre proférant
grand de nantes mais pour prendre les
franchement de leur entrée et dans le
diplomatie publique ils ont déjà lâché
la laisse les américaines ont dit leur
conscience ce sont des centres aux
troupes russes à la frontière de
l'ukraine et la possibilité d'une
attaque et pour la russie c'est la
menace depuis plus que trois décennies
que l'otan va avancer jusqu'à la
frontière de la russie est donc
maintenant les problèmes sociaux le
câble il n'y a aucune raison parce que
pour l'instant un négoce bilatérales
positionnelle n'arrive pas dans une
solution et est bien sûr un négoce motti
la terreur sur juste des courtils ils
ont le singe est évitée en spectacle
comme ça les partenaires européens des
états unis ont été consultés avant cette
rencontre à genève mais ils redoutent
effectivement d'être marginalisés
douglas y est ça vous venez de l'évoquer
pour quelles raisons est ce que les
européens ont été écartés de ce face à
face entre les etats-unis et la russie
carine micha golovkov selon vous les
jets les européens sont écartés parce
qu'ils se sont
écartés eux mêmes être de la
géopolitique à partir du moment où ils
sont entrés d'angel la globalisation et
où ils sont devenus en fait des pions
dans le jeu qui se joue entre d'un côté
les intérêts atlantiste et de l'autre
côté le jeu qui est menée notamment par
la russie qui essayent de développer un
monde multilatéral
mais ce qui est intéressant et comme
vient de souligner votre invité c'est
que nous sommes en fait dans un schéma
en quelque sorte de discussion pour la
discussion puisque finalement ni d'un
côté ni de l'autre nous n'attendons
réellement de résultat est d'une
certaine manière
c'est un jeu qui est certes a peut être
intéressant si on tourne la
communication mais quand la
communication devient un but en soi le
problème c'est qu'elle empêche la
politique c'est à dire qu'elles
empêchent la véritable prise de décision
et lorsque l'on voit la réaction des
états unis puisque l'on parle de
sécurité quand même lorsque l'on voit la
réaction des états unis lorsque le
kazakhstan demande l'aide à handicap et
à l'organisation du traité de la
sécurité collective alors que le
kazakhstan est membre de cette
organisation est que les états unis
demandent des explications l'on peut se
demander réellement quelles concessions
ils sont prêts à faire sérieusement en
tout cas pas dans le discours pas dans
la communication mais si on parle
réellement de décision politique et là
il serait peut-être intéressant que les
pays qui veulent réellement rétablir une
sécurité
sérieuses réel sur leur territoire
reprenant ma leur agenda politique
c'est-à-dire sorte de cet agenda qui est
totalement dictée par l'agenda global
liste a et remettent à l'ordre du jour
leurs intérêts nationaux nous avions la
russie pour le faire washington a
déclaré qu'il n'y aura pas de
discussions sur la sécurité européenne
sont nos alliés et partenaires européens
en fin de citation double assiettes
c'est ce que c'est un test aussi font
les états unis de john dryden qui ont
échaudé leurs alliés européens en
donnant l'impression jusque là de faire
cavalier seul sur plusieurs dossiers
oui après l'administration 30 jours by
jove renforcer la communauté
transatlantique
mais comment avoue avec afghanistan ça
veut dire pas qu'il va faire tous les
décisions pour voir et il a appris les
leçons qu'il faut consulter ses
partenaires européennes donc ils feront
après génère il va se rencontrer
macro ni il allait prendre avec le haut
et c est avec ottawa mais c'est après
les négoces trek avec la russie en
revanche derrière tout ça une club
français de brydon c'est les états unis
veulent réduire leurs forces militaro il
veut repositionner leurs forces en
d'ofra civique pour qu'on tienne sur
complique avec la chine et il a c'est
peut-être la chance pour les cordes ça
veut dire que poutine en voici son tir
est en sécurité pour arrêter
l'avancement l'expansion d'autant avec
une zone du tampon en ukraine les états
unis veut réduire leurs forces au nord
pour les positionner en 1/2 po syfy
peut-être ce soit compromise comme été
fait dans les années 30 qui est le grand
léjon des états unis de la deuxième
guerre mondiale
ces api sme
msf est peut-être mois que le menace
fait de la montée de puissance de la
chine en tout cas le crâne reste
toujours dans le proche
étrangères de la russie ici très loin
des etats-unis et pour revenir sur les
propositions faites par la russie aux
états unis ces propositions sont selon
moscou le moyen de rétablir une
coopération russe occidental je cite en
l'absence totale de confiance mutuelle
et compte tenu de la politique de l'otan
car il met gigolo faut qu est-ce que
l'otan avait promis à la russie au
sortir de la guerre froide est ce que
les promesses ont été tenues
au sortir de la guerre froide l'otan
avait promis de ne à s'étendre vers
l'est à aa or nous avons vieux que les
temps s'est étendue vers l'est le
problème est de savoir à ce que même si
à l'otan les états unis d'un heure
d'accord pour ratifier des traités
qu'elle est finalement le poids de ces
traités quelle sera leur force
finalement les succès traité n'aurait
que le poids que l'otan et les états
unis voudraient bien leur accorder c'est
à dire qu'il n'aurait finalement
réellement pas plus de poids que la
paroles verbales qui a été donnée à
l'époque pourquoi parce qu'ils auront
droit international
les actes juridiques imposées sont le
résultat d'un rapport de force politique
est-ce que la russie actuellement est en
position pour imposer le respect de ces
traités si jamais il était négociée même
si on rappellera quand même que pour
l'instant et l'otan et les états unis
refusent à priori de toute manière c'est
à ces traités donc la russie aurait tel
intérêt aurais tu es les moyens de le
faire oui en principe elle l'aurait mais
pour cela il faudrait que l aussie sort
de l'agenda globaliste et à la des
moyens totalement asymétrique pour
réagir elle peut reconnaître par exemple
ou menacées de reconnaître les résultats
du à
du référendum d'autodétermination dans
basse si jamais
les programmes de l'otan continuent à se
développer en ukraine elle peut aussi
remettre en cause l'agenda que vit 10
des qr codes et cetera qui se développe
en russie c'est aussi un moyen de faire
pression sur
l'action les états unis dans ces
négociations qui ce qu'on voit quand
même que la déstabilisation sociale et
économique qui découle de cette crise
sanitaire provoque une crise de
légitimité des pouvoirs nationaux qui
rentre totalement dans les intérêts de
levet l'istat donc il y a tout à fait
des moyens pour réagir mais pour cela il
faudra aussi une prise de décision
politique et ça ne s'arrêtera pas
simplement avec la négociation de
traités derniers mois s'est rapidement
avec vous aussi vous voulez bien de
glace et c'est ce que vous vous diriez
que finalement c'est l'ordre européen
défini pendant et après la guerre froide
qui est en jeu aujourd'hui
oui et donc et dans cet enjeu marcal
située au niveau 1 les européennes sont
un bavoir et maintenant avec joe boyd
qui est en niveau 1 on va voir est ce
qu'il est prêt vraiment à tuer pour
protéger l'ukraine ou est-ce que ce soit
encore un grand promise comment vous
avec 98 ou deux
merci beaucoup on aura l'occasion de
revenir sur ces discussions évidemment
qu'on va suivre avec intérêt ce sur
notre antenne merci à vous donc
l'assiette ce professeur de droit et
spécialiste de sciences politiques
américaines merci à vous car il m'est
cher au losc au professeur invité à
l'université d'état de moscou